Alright guys, so in this video I'm going to talk about confirmation entries and I did not make a video about confirmation entries in the, you know, my course videos so I thought maybe I should share it with you guys and it's helping me a lot. It has helped me a lot and it's also going to help you a lot with the, with your win rate. Okay, so you are going to miss the trades sometimes but when you're going to take those trades
they gonna actually work out. So let's take ABC as an example. So let's say that you are
looking at ABC right on a five minute time from. So you have these small little pullbacks
then you have this one large pullback and then you have this big pullback. I was sorry, push
up again. So textbook ABC right we have taken out the high. So then on the five
minute let's say we are looking at the five minute time from right so on the
five minute we have a marker structure shift right following all the rules. So
you would have your free body gap or auto block marked up here right. So now
When you have your favorable gap and auto block marked, you want to drop down to the one minute timeframe or a smaller timeframe.
This was on the five minute.
So when you're going to drop down to the one minute, you're going to see a structure like this.
So on a smaller timeframe, one minute, you also wait for market structure shift through your POI.
So on a bigger timeframe we have a BC, right?
And then we have a market structure shift
on a bigger timeframe.
Once you have market structure shift
and you mark your POI,
you wanna drop down to the smaller timeframe
and wait for fractal confirmation, right?
You wanna wait for confirmation.
So on the one way, you wait for market structure shift again
with displacement.
And I'm gonna talk about displacement
in the coming videos.
So then you take your entry from here.
After market is received, you take your entry.
And this is going to increase the win rate
because this is confirmation rate
that the auto flow is now bearish.
So you can target something like this and can work out.
When you are not using confirmation entries,
what sometimes can happen is,
you have your ABC and you have broke the structure.
Price can simply just stop you out.
So I think it's better to look for confirmation entries.
When you have your ABC setup, you wait for confirmation
on smaller time frame.
So let's say that you are looking at the ABC on one
hour time frame and you have your market structure shift.
And then you have a PUI on the one hour time frame.
You want to drop down to the five minute time frame.
And then you want to look for a confirmation like this.
So you have a break on the five minute timeframe.
And you have your free body gap or OB here.
And then you take your entry from this level,
put your stop there, and Kaboom.
So this can be used with any strategy that I've taught you
guys.
So let's assume that we are looking at the autoflow trading
strategy. So on the one hour time from we have you know like a change of
connector here or market structure shift whatever you want to call it and then
we have our auto block here. So when when you have a market structure shift
what you want to do is you want to drop down to a smaller time from like 15
minute or five minute. I would say I dropped down to 15 minute right so you would
have a structure like this then and then you wait for market structure shift on a 15 minute
timeframe, right? You break the structure on the 15 minute timeframe. Remember we had a change
of connector on a one hour timeframe and then we had air confirmation from the POI from the one
RPOI on the 15 minute timeframe. So when you have a market structure shift, you can just take your
entry from this level here and you go along here and you put your stop there and
Kaboom. It's gonna work out in your favor. So what it does is first of all it
just gives you a better wrist-to-award entry and secondly it increases your
increases the chances of that trade going in your direction. So you want to
consider using the confirmation entry tactic in your,
um, in your strategy.
Now, this is going to take some backtesting because,
uh, for some people,
this might not be suitable because sometimes what price will do is, um,
let me draw this out, right?
So you have your purei here.
Right? So let me draw this out.
So what's going to happen is you're going to get your, uh,
confirmation mark on the shift, but price will not come back.
to the lower time for MPUI, your entry point,
and it's just gonna keep on going up.
So this can happen and you are going to miss out the trade.
But what's beneficial, what's the plus amount of this thing
is that you're gonna get a better ratio award
and you're also going to increase your win rate.
So make sure that you take this into consideration.
Also, a lot of people mess up this one thing.
So you want to go to the indicators and type in ICT kills on.
So you are going to have like kills on what is kills on is like the London session and the
New York session and there's specific timing that you should be using for your trades
because at that time is when the algorithms are active.
So you're going to have a kills London kills on and then you're going to have a New York
I'm gonna show you the indicator as well.
That is gonna show you the kill zones.
So your entry must be, so you have like,
a break of structure here.
So now, sorry, change of particular market
to share, you have market structure shift here, right?
So what, you don't wanna take your trade
outside the kill zone, you wanna take your entry
during the kill zone hour.
So let's suppose this is London,
Kildon, right?
So you have your entry and boom.
Similarly over here, you wanna wait for,
price to give you the entry
during the New York Kildon.
So this is a must thing.
And a lot of people must have stopped
they take trades during long,
during a wrong timing.
And it could be the reason why
the trade doesn't work out in your favor.
So in this lecture what I've taught you is a confirmation entries, right?
And I've also taught as the KillZuns how they are beneficial for your win rate.
So if I go here, let me go to the fight minutavre.
I have the, yep, so there we have our KillZuns.
You can see this is the London Kilzone, and this is the New York Kilzone that you are looking at.
So your entry must be between these ours.
It's that simple.
So you can see that actually for indices, personally I would still be looking to trade till
before take my entry before 11.59.
But over here, this skills on indicator says that 1040.
And also, this is an actual kill zone, right?
Which ICT teaches.
But for indices, you can go till 11.59.
If you get actually, I would correct myself there.
I messed up.
When the clock hits 12 on indices, if you are in a trade, you should close it immediately because price can reverse.
Alright, so the best time would be till 1130. If you get your entry at 1130, that's prime.
Okay, you don't want to hold your trade till 12. You want to close it before 12.
So yeah, make sure you know that.
So yeah, I'll end this lecture here and we'll continue with other tactics.